Dragon Ball super is Goku blacker
it doesn't make any sense
no I don't smell leader or whatever your
preferred unit of measurement is and I
emphasize this because this arc broke my
brain now I'm not gonna lie to you guys
this week's video it's gonna be a tough
one this is gonna test our relationship
more than that one episode of Dragon
Ball super where berry Khan tries to
convince Vidal that her good boy Gohan
was cheating on her with actual
photographic evidence and yes that
actually happens but more importantly I
need you guys to be my bedell on this
one
during this video I might say some
things that you might disagree with but
through all of this I will try to
explain myself as best I can and that I
love you I need you to look at this
picture of me kissing Goku black I
understand that I'm doing this not
because I want to god no no I'm kissing
Goku black because I have to for us I'm
doing this for us now at this point I'm
aware that this time looked like I'm
stalling like I don't want to start this
video and that's because you're right
well I do remember and join this arc of
the show I'm also keenly aware that it
doesn't make a single ounce of sense and
I fear that my second trip around the
block might take me over the edge but
again I do this for us so I'm totally
not mark and this is my review for
Dragon Ball super z' Goku black arc
Oh hold on I'm gonna quickly mention
this before I start my main review there
were a number of filler episodes that
took place between this arc and the last
five episodes in total to be exact
they don't really connect anything and
could easily be cut without any
consequence to the continuity but
because I know you're gonna ask my
opinion on them here it is superfast
episode 42 totally fine somewhat fun
episode where we get a rematch between
Goku and beerus sort of it's some slice
of life hammers fun to help unwind after
the tournament nothing major episode 43
this is the really weird episode that
introduces what i thought was at the
time a new mechanic goku losing control
of his ki due to his use of super saiyan
blue in tandem with the kaio-ken
technique but it turned out to be a
once-off never again having consequence
in the rest of the series to date
despite goku using that exact same
tandem technique a number of times
thereafter episodes 44 or 45 and 46 this
filler AK is something that i thought
could have been quite good actually but
was only okay really at the end of the
day the first episode is largely set up
and boring the second episode is
interesting getting to see Vegeta deal
with the loss of his power and the third
is a really underwhelming rematch of the
goku vs vegeta fight overall I thought
these were mostly boring and nothing to
write home about okay it's time for
black suit 47 this is the best first
episode to any arc of any Dragonball
anything I have ever seen ever this
might also be the single most
interesting and compelling Dragon Balls
villain introduction the show once again
has ever unveiled at least to me all the
parts are there opening effectively and
fast by setting the scene establishing
the hero and the current objective
remaining undetected by a shadowy figure
in the sky trunks is reality really
can't seem to catch a break here and
it's not even five minutes in then his
mom dies in a really tragic way right in
front of him before he's given the
responsibility to flee to the past once
again to search for help we then get
introduced to my similar in age now two
trunks their relationship is also given
time to breathe as they eat cat food
again showing how dire the situation is
for their timeline once again trunks
this time with my run
into the shadowy figure in the sky on
their way back to the time machine
my is taken out but not really and
finally the shadowy figure is revealed
okay though for real when this episode
first aired literally everyone had that
face on ironically episode 48 the best
parts of this episode are its beginning
and end predominantly it's beginning
continuing on from the last episode in
the future timeline trunks is still
cornered by the looming threat of Goku
black and so is forced into direct
conflict once again this is a great
continuation from the previous episode
keeping the tone and the drama intact
trunks manages to distract Goku black
long enough to piece out from that
timeline and land himself into the
present main timeline we are familiar
with leaving G be all kinds of confused
some stuff with trunks and goten in
school takes place future Trump's
arrives causing everyone to wig out and
everyone dashes to the rescue he's
zapped of energy and out cold
Goku get some sense of beans corn and
yajuro BR playing limbo and trunks wakes
up next episode 49 okay so this fight it
doesn't actually happen unless you mean
this fight that stolen land is like ten
minutes later in which case yes that
absolutely happens trunks is brought up
to speed he even explains how he dealt
with majin buu which is a nice touch I
think before going on to explain the
whole evil Goku snitches timeline has
been dealing with almost all of humanity
has been destroyed and that they're in a
pretty desperate situation beerus and
whis are not too happy about this time
manipulation which honestly doesn't tell
me anything other than that the writers
needed away for beers and wheeze to not
get involved with trunks this timeline
which again if I'm being perfectly
honest is probably the most
straightforward thing they did during
this arc oh and Goku black discovers
that trunks escape to another time
before following him and showing up at
the end of this episode in the present
cliffhanger episode 50 I really like
this episode and it's so pretty
this episode is supervised by yuuichi
Kurosawa and I just think it looks
pretty ok but like most things I have my
issues with it I'll get all the bat out
of the way first it's clear that the
writers didn't put a ton of care into
getting Goku and Goku black into the
same space for their first encounter
it's explained that Goku black followed
the tear in time trunks his time machine
left behind and I'm like okay but then
he gets pulled back in time because the
tear is closing or something like
but look just say it you wanted Goku and
Goku black to fight and this was the
only way you could make it work while
also keeping them apart but whatever
aside from that the fight between Goku
black and Goku has some seriously
polished and crisp at work while also
showcasing some really interesting and
fun fight choreography it also stands in
direct contrast with the rest of the arc
which spoiler alert is completely
shrouded in darkness like 90% of the
time before piecing out black destroys
trunks his time machine for some reason
I thought he wanted trunks to be
destroyed why would he get rid of his
only way back to the future to be fair
that is a minor nitpick and maybe black
made a last-minute decision not a big
deal
thankfully though once everything calms
down Bulma reveals that she kept the
extra Time Machine cell used during the
cell's saga that's a really cool
throwback and one that really does a
fantastic job at linking the past with
the present of Super in fact I'd go as
far as to say that it's the best
callback to the Past so far easily I
don't think I would ever have even
thought of that episode 51 my is an
older lady trapped inside a kid body
whose best friends are a dog and a small
gremlin man to me her having a thing
with trunks is weird and I can't shake
that also this episode is total filler
and completely boring goo goo Goo's off
to training King Kai's bearson Huizar
suspicious of the ki given off by Goku
black and the evil boy's plans are laid
to bear next episode 52 another filler
noting episode that I found insanely
boring which is weird because the
beginning of the act is such a great job
of sucking me in and getting the tension
going much like the last episode Bulma
is still working on the time machine
repairing it what follows honestly
doesn't really impact anything it could
be removed and nothing would change
trunks tracks down Gohan to meet up the
eat ice cream and have dinner go on
having ice cream before dinner if you're
a fan of Gohan and enjoy this
interaction I get it but I personally
found it to be a pointless distraction
and very boring when trunks returns home
from his day of debauchery with Dragon
Balls bad boy he finds out that beerus
Wiese and goku are travelling to another
universe to investigate the mysterious
key of goku black episode 53 I actually
really really like this episode it's
mostly talking but does have some action
a decent chunk of comedy with stupid
super Goku but more importantly deals
with introduces and establishes the
foundational motivations for one of the
most important characters
the ark samus the individual next in
line to be the supreme kai of universe
10 there's a nice exchange between go ah
sued the current Supreme Kai of universe
10 and his pupils samus who upon
entering the scene presents tea to his
master Glossop explains that the tea is
a reflection of his pure heart and as a
result will taste wonderful with the
focus on the teacup itself zammis who
goes on to ask wasu questions regarding
mankind's deserve it nests of their
watchful eye this conflicted outlook in
za mas whose head also clouds the tegu
was drinking and he notices this I
thought that was a really nice inclusion
there's a whole mess of stupid super
Goku being annoying that I'm choosing to
ignore and skip because I hate it the
fight between Zama Sioux and Goku is
actually interesting and fun albeit
short facilitating an elegant way for
beers and weeds to better understand who
black really is episode 54 there are a
bunch of episodes that happen after the
initial story beats are ironed out that
really feel like padding trunks chilling
out my and the pilaf gang doing various
things and no more waiting around while
Bulma adds the finishing touches to the
time machine thankfully though in this
episode we finally get something at
least a little bit interesting we
haven't really as I've yet had a chance
to see Vegeta and trunks interact much
since he returned and so if nothing else
this scene needed to take place Vegeta
spars with trunks testing his abilities
introducing trunks of Super Saiyan blue
and finally instilling within him the
desire to always strive to be stronger
the episode itself ends proper as a
masseuse disillusionment arc continues
to spiral out of control his master gua
soo seen this decides to show za Masood
the time rings how to use them and
decides to bring the young Kai into the
future of a particular race of mortals
on planet Barbary episode 55
so the point gasa was trying to make
fors imasu on planet barberries future
completely backfires and only reinforces
the believes imasu already held on too
tightly now having seen his master
shocked by the events that took place
under his own control Hamas who now has
all the proof he needs to know that what
he feels is in fact correct
he must enact his plan to eradicate
humanity on the other set of things Ino
requests Goku to come over he wants to
be friends with him apparently sonority
likes him and decides to give Goku a
button and not just any button a
two-sided button that can bring Goku to
0 or Z no to goku depending on which
side he presses beerus naturally is
terrified at the idea of this for
obvious reasons the
ends with Goku Vegeta and trunks finally
boarding the now finally repaired time
machine and arriving in trunks is future
however upon arrival they get attacked
almost immediately by the Earth's
remaining forces episode 56 this man
isn't black what who said Dragon Ball
doesn't have social commentary for real
though this episode is actually quite
good and I really enjoyed it
it's the first time the characters from
Goku's timeline get to see trunks is
affected future and man is it in a rank
we follow future my as Schiele is the
resistance against Goku black before she
leads trunks Goku and Vegeta through the
catacombs and Subway's they are forced
to live in so few people remain left
alive and she blames herself for not
being strong enough or enough to protect
them all Goku and everyone puts this
insecurity to rest quickly thankfully
these small character interactions felt
very genuine and set the tone for the
upcoming battles brilliantly this is
what trunks is fighting for the little
children soldiers and families all
living in squalor and fear underneath
the streets of their destroyed and
tortured world Vegeta feels confident
and ready leading into challenge Goku
black right away black arrives on the
scene they fight leading to black
revealing his beautiful super saiyan
rosey appears and vegeta is taken out
immediately because of course he is I
guess someone has to act as a
sacrificial lamb to create the
cliffhanger for this episode episode 57
this episode is mostly action whether
that's a good or a bad thing I guess
we'll find out on a visual front first
and foremost the episode contains some
of the best animated scenes Dragon Ball
super has delivered so far supplied by
Naruto shi shi de a fantastic action
animator famous at this point for
working on the original Dragon Ball Z
anime and for supplying that awesome
cloud fight sequence between Goku and
beerus in the battle of gods movie and
know this will not be the last time we
see his work in Dragon Ball super or
even this arc so get hyped for that but
even taking that shortcut he supplied
out the artwork direction and and in
parts animation within this episode are
largely far above this series average
which is honestly a great site from a
story point of view this is where things
start getting really silly though while
Goku being able to keep up with back is
somewhat believable trunks doing so is
most certainly not someone who was being
schooled by black in his base state
while he was in
per se inform should not be able to do
what he's doing in this scene against a
super powered super saiyan Rose a Goku
black it's ridiculous and makes zero
sense even with his little rage boost
which I wonder how many more of those
were gonna get they get defeated by
black and some ah sue but thankfully are
rescued by a gob and my sending them
back to the past in a beaten heap I
guess it's back to the drawing board
episode 58 oh also I should say that in
the last episode I made I said that
pseudo wasn't ever used again
I was actually completely wrong my bad I
still think he's a dumb idea that
creates far more problems than there
needs to be but at least he wasn't a
once-off so that's something pseudo
fills the masu in at all that he needs
to know about the super Dragon Balls and
we cut back to the house where we see
more stupid super Goku he forgot to
bring the Senzu beans that they've
prepared wait what he forgot yeah you
know he forgot you know cuz Goku stupid
while Goku kind of forgot about the iron
fleet and Euron's forces
I mean Senzu beans and blacks forces I
sit back in my chair cringing again
another moment where the writing staff
had no idea how to create a scene
without compromising either logic or
character could you imagine the Goku who
prepared for the androids of making this
mistake the answer no episode 59 so in
this episode beerus we sin and goku
because he needs to be in almost every
episode for some reason arrived in
universe tend to try to figure out if
samus ooo is in fact sinister they can't
exactly reprimand him just yet as
technically he hasn't done anything too
wrong yet and so they need to test him
for proof and they do pretty much just
that tomas who does the deal and go ah
sue reese rewinds time and beerus are
Kai's him out of existence it's a cool
scene punctuated beautifully by the
score but there's not much to it in the
way of narrative structure it's just
cool to finally see beerus actually do
something also beerus is convinced that
this will fix all the timelines despite
everyone knowing that that's not how
time travel works in Dragonball other
than that in this episode trunks has a
pep talk with trunks so that's weird
albeit sort of cute episode 60 so the
gang decided to go back to the future to
see if the timeline has been
miraculously fixed thanks to beerus can
I just ask why are they going back
nothing about them is different here
they are just as strong and on
as they were before only this time they
have sent two beans they were completely
outmatched last time this is one of
those moments in the anime that I think
works far better in the manga now I
intentionally haven't mentioned the
manga because I wanted to focus on the
anime here primarily but for the sake of
this point I'll use it as reference in
the anime they go to the Future three
times
in the manga they go just twice once
they fail they regroup and prepare as
best they can before returning finally
for the last time they didn't do this in
the anime until the third time for some
reason fool me once shame on you so they
go back to the future and just when I
thought they couldn't make Goku's
character any weirder they decide that
he needed to have this bit of exposition
[Music]
like he has two sons think about that
how creepy is that well thankfully B and
Z show up to save this awkward scene and
Vegeta finally attacks episode 61 so
it's revealed that samaithu is immortal
finally and that Goku black took out
Goku already in a different timeline I'm
not gonna try to make sense of this
timey wimey stuff right now because it
doesn't actually make any sense if you
really think about it and I value what's
left of my sanity right now we sees a
mass - and Goku black hog for a little
too long but you know name a more iconic
couple Jennifer Aniston and Brad Pitt
eat your heart out it's revealed to Goku
how black disposed of his family and him
which leads to Goku getting all sorts of
mad now don't get me wrong it is a cool
scene but it's difficult for me to
understand why he wouldn't be just as
upset like that over Bulma dying
I guess because he has to have those
hilarious scenes where he acts like an
idiot around imasu maybe what would
Dragon Ball super do without that
Goku black pulls a weird new move out of
his butt I mean discovers new depths to
his power and takes Goku out once again
black starts posturing and gloating and
making all sorts of evil noises as
trunks looks on leading to trunks
receiving his second unreasonable power
boost of the arc at least this time it
looks cool episode 62 okay it doesn't
look cool anymore it looks awful make it
stop please make it stop
okay so get this trunks on his own holds
off a super-powered Goku black and an
immortal Samus ooh
well Goku
and vegeta both escaped back to the past
for a second time goku literally starts
laughing about how he punched himself
too chichi and vegeta flies off to
better himself before the next fight
like you should have done the last time
oh actually okay goku heads over to
Master Roshi's to learn the math Oba
which if I'm being completely honest is
an ingenious way of dealing with an
immortal villain that I personally had
forgotten about episode 63 meanwhile in
the future my decides that the best
course of action that she should take is
to shoot Goku black with a gun yep well
that didn't work and oh look another
unrealistic fight scene showing trunks
acting wave way more powerful that he
should be if this story actually made
sense but at least it looks pretty soon
as Vegeta Bulma and koku arrived back in
the future to help trunks black destroys
the time machine immediately which is
honestly a good idea okay look there's
been City moments in this show so far
but they have a good plan right now with
the mokuba and there's time to deliver a
great third act so fingers crossed let's
do this goku vegeta start fighting black
and xylose soon vegeta just Rex black
and it's really satisfying
satisfying because you know how much it
means for vegeta to take revenge and the
guy that defeated him personally and who
ruined his son's life it's a great scene
with some classic vegeta one-liners
episode 64 Vegeta continues to school on
black until black learns that Saiyans
get their power through anger and then
stabs his own and to turn his energy
sword into a scythe just in case the
Grim Reaper metaphor wasn't lost than
any of us it's at this point Goku black
turns into a ridiculous character
crapping out new techniques without he
even knowing what the hell is going on
like it gets really silly well this is
all happening trunks learns them off
about in like a few moments and captures
the marsupial a it turns out that Goku
once again kind of forgot they aren't
fleed and Euron's forces he forgotten
the damn seal for the mouth about to
actually work I hate this earth this was
a great way for the story to dispose of
an immortal character and now it goes
right down the toilet
time to go full marketing dummy mode now
Fusion has joined the chat episode 65
now do you remember how much more
powerful Vegeta was then Goku and Vegeta
separately well I do and there's no
earthly or godly way that fusuma suit
should have any problem dispensing of
either Goku Vegeta or trunks even if
they teamed up but whatever cool fight
seems got to happen I guess and they
don't know how to do that while making
sense there's a neat father-son gallic
gun scene that's okay despite it not
making any sense how they're holding the
masu back but that pales in comparison
to how goku alone holds his blast back
power scaling matters this is just
confusing and weird episode 66 this is
the big action episode and it feels like
that in every sense of the word from the
pacing to the tension to the set piece
and even to the sense of desperation
that builds up towards the end I don't
think I even need to go over what
happens in this episode you've all
already seen it it looks visually very
impressive and has some really nice
ideas for techniques too like thick foil
Kamehameha just a tasteful fit a
fanservice with that one but what aspect
a lot of people seem to dislike about
this episode was how they handled the
diffusion of the two main characters
Goku and Vegeta it's revealed in this
episode that there is in fact a time
limit for mortals wearing these earrings
this is my take on this scene this is
not a red card a red con is a change to
a previously established rule this
forever fusion with the earrings was
once a rule yes but because pacino
diffused in the boom saga without any
explanation the red con doesn't happen
in Super it happens in the boosts ugh
the only thing super did was offer an
explanation for that diffusion so stop
being babies about it I'm not defending
this arc by any means but I'm not gonna
criticize it over something it didn't do
I'm genuinely trying to be fair here the
fight as I said was fantastic but as
I've explained the two diffuse because
tension needs to happen in trunks hops
in the final moments to make the save
I love how of the corruption arc that
samaithu has gone on has manifested
visually in his appearance the choices
he's made having left his face and body
grotesque and disfigured he screams at
trunks both menacingly an unconditioned
his character has ended up in against
the virtuous hero of trunks and I can
even make peace with fuse the Mastiff
being weakened after his battle with
Vegeta or with him being emotionally
compromised enough for trunk
to make a difference here sort of but
then this happens so trunks can do the
spirit bomb with his sword despite never
having learned the move it never been
foreshadowed or it even been mentioned a
single time within the entire story
within the black universe six
resurrection F or battle of gods arcs
okay this is so unbelievably dumb like
it looks cool but it is a massive deus
ex machina call me out of thin air to
facilitate attending the writing staff
or Akira Toriyama didn't plan for it's a
truly awful ending episode 67 an arc
that started with the best first episode
I've ever seen now ends with the single
worst ending I've ever seen literally
every single character except for Mayan
trunks from that time line dies remember
those soldiers den remember you had your
OB and the other civilians dead remember
those little children that started
cheering for trunks first giving him the
energy he needed to save the world well
they're super dead I'm not even dead in
the traditional Dragon Ball sense of the
word where they effectively just go to a
different part of the universe forever
oh god no they are dead dead like they
don't even nor can they ever exist
anymore and why is this a problem well
because it makes the entire and I mean
entire arc ultra Li painfully and
irreversibly pointless so Hamas who
becomes the sky because he's immortal
and that's what immortals do if they've
fused with immortal and get slice in
half apparently Goku has the bright idea
then to smash this in a button and the
little guy literally erases the entire
universe so that's fine trunks name goes
on to live with future my and Future
Trunks in a timeline where the events of
black never happened living with
themselves and no
mensches why this is such a horrific
existential nightmare and the arc comes
to a close
everyone is weirdly happy and Trunks
leaves crying as he looks at Gohan who
played virtually no role in this arc
what's happening okay
I've mentioned the story doesn't make
sense numerous times during this video
and I understand that a lot of people
can look past that because things look
cool so why does something not making
sense stop someone like me from enjoying
something well take this for an example
imagine you have two men fighting on a
log floating on a giant lake it's just a
regular lake with nothing special about
it it's in the real world both can swim
and suddenly one kicks the other into
water suddenly the man's submerged in
water without warning spontaneously
catches fire and explodes this would be
a bad ending because it breaks the rules
of how we understood that scene should
work a story works the same way if it
ending breaks the established logic and
rules put in place it feels in
nonsensical lazy and idiotic an example
of a good piece of storytelling was seen
in episode 53 it's believable that
beerus and whis would recognize black
ski from zammis whose fight with goku as
it is an established part of how powers
in the show work it also stands to
reason za masu wouldn't be on the
defensive because he would have no
knowledge of the events and he hasn't
become evil yet so that works but this
arc is filled with a lot of really and I
mean really stupid choices for the story
not because they were choices made by
dumb people far from it Tony has shown
that they can write compelling episodes
time and again what is abundantly clear
to me looking at the choices they have
made however is that they are
uncompromising ly focused on one thing
above all else marketing they are not
concerned about telling a compelling
thought-provoking or well written story
first and foremost they're concerned
with what will get the audience's
excited via trailer the most Future
Trunks does absolutely nothing in this
except learn all the same lessons he did
in the cell saga in order to keep him
relevant with the main cast and
competent in the fight scenes he gets
one absurd power boost after another
climaxing in a finish that while
delivered in favor of the right person
and while appropriately visually
striking it is carried out utilizing a
technique with no prior foreshadowing
established his
three or anything really it comes out of
nowhere because the Reuters had nothing
established for the character to carry
out his Big Finish the original first
Super Saiyan transformation with Goku
anomic against Frieza worked because it
was foreshadowed the same for Goku
teleporting cell away during the cell
Games the same for the Spirit Bomb
against Vegeta these were all satisfying
finishes utilizing techniques that had
been clearly established prior to their
use in their respective climaxes and if
you don't believe me that marketing was
the driving force for a lot of these
decisions Vegeta the fusion of Goku and
Vegeta is supposed to wear a combination
of clothes Goku and Vegeta were
currently wearing before they threw the
old bling on their ears but they ignore
that in super because that's what
Vegeta's toy is supposed to look like
and they can change that Goku black and
the Masters existence didn't make any
sense within the established logic of
the show and I'm saying this now the
Canon explanation is wrong but to
explain why believe me will require a
long explanation because believe it or
not it's stupidly complicated with so
many moving parts it's a wonder Toei
were able to bluff their way through
using it though it does explain why so
many people don't notice that it doesn't
make sense in the community it's way too
convoluted to even figure out completely
I fully intend on addressing and
explaining why this particular Canon
explanation is wrong but that will take
an entire video and trust me this will
be a long entirely separate video also
the ending of the arc is I think the
biggest slap in the face Dragon Ball has
ever to this date delivered to its
audience not only are there no
consequences leading on from this arc
but the means with which they revert
back to the status quo is insultingly
lazy and disrespectful to the
intelligence of the fans that diligently
followed along week after week in
addition to all of this scattered
throughout our various sections of
exposition and info delivered seemingly
without any thought or care put into how
it would affect the established world
Goku has never kissed chichi what
drones can do a spear bomb with his
sword what everyone dies and nothing
matters and I'm sad now what and those
are my thoughts on the Goku black arc
it's mindless but it is visually fun so
if you turn off your brain I'm sure
there's plenty to enjoy I just happen to
really not
like it's this type if you enjoyed this
series subscribe and hit that
notification Bell if you want the
subscription to work and leave a like if
you enjoyed but until next week I've
been totally not mark thank you so much
for watching
[Music]